you might recall this scene playing out  last  wednesday night on on south sixth street  near charleston and las vegas boulevard  uh what i'm looking for is for the girl  that's in the house to come out here  because i'm gonna a ring doorbell  capturing a man making threats against  the woman who was  inside the home alone today we learned  he has been identified by police  as 40-year-old christopher sumps that's  his mug shot there on your screen that's  according to his arrest report obtained  by our eye team he was arrested the next  day and is facing charges including  aggravated stalking  and attempted burglary since he is a  fugitive out of california police say  he's being held without bail